lucrative troubled and turbulent is the
Glazer family's tenure at Manchester
United nearing the final whistle almost
20 years after taking control of
arguably the world's most famous
football club The Old Trafford outfit
has confirmed an exclusive Sky news
report that its owners are exploring a
sale the glazes have been controversial
figures throughout their time at United
and the lack of a premier league title
since 2013 has only intensified fans
antipathy it is 17 years where the club
was Laden with a lot of debt which has
not been paid down the levels of debt
the same today as they were in 2005
and that's led to a lack of investment
both in the playing side and we see that
on the pitch but also in the stadium the
state of Old Trafford that used to be
you know one of our great sources of
Pride and it isn't anymore
[Applause]
foreign
European Super League provided one of
many flashpoints
and it may be the failure of that
project which has finally persuaded the
owners to sell absolutely without
question uh the last 10 years of the
stewardship has been not far short of
disastrous it's the business model
they've established it is incorrect and
wrong they pay themselves dividends the
only Premier League club where directors
pay themselves dividends time is right
to sell
the Glazer's depth fuel take over 17
years ago preceded a boom in the
valuations of England's top football
clubs the American Family paid 790
million pounds earlier this year Chelsea
changed hands for two and a half billion
pounds Liverpool is now reportedly up
for sale with a price tag of more than 4
billion pounds and United stock market
valuation of around 1.8 billion pounds
is likely to be far exceeded in a
bidding war
the hoisting of the for sale sign during
a World Cup fueled by petrodollars
provides a fitting Financial backdrop
sir Jim Ratcliffe the chemicals Tycoon
who claimed to want to buy United
earlier this year recently described
English football's Elite as overvalued
that won't deter cash Rich bidders
seeking the ultimate trophy asset it may
be no coincidence that the owners of
United and Liverpool have simultaneously
decided to exploit their own version of
football's transfer window the
challenging economic backdrop and the
resulting uncertainty for future
broadcasting commercial income May mean
that the Sport's most valuable
franchises have little room to generate
even greater riches for their owners
of course it's not the only high profile
departure from the club after weeks of
speculation Cristiano Ronaldo is also
leaving but the Glazer family's
potential exit will upstage that of even
one of the world's best known players
for so long the target of supporters
anger love United hate Glazer could soon
be a chant consigned to the Old Trafford
history books
Mark Kleinman Sky News in Manchester